hello everyone and welcome to Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong I'm your real
Jacqueline back with Mr Mark Ellis I
will say sir it's just good to see you
at a consistent basis it's good to see
you and boy did we have fun last night
we did have fun last night ladies and
gentlemen occasionally I will text Mark
and say hey do you want to go to a movie
most the time he says no because he's a
busy man and you know dog stepfather I
pretend to be busy but last night I got
you and it was I think very fitting
considering the movie we're doing today
yeah yeah so Jacqueline invited me as
her plus wanted to go see Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part one
nailed it and uh and so we watched that
in anticipation of this movie that we're
talking about which I actually watched
on a plane coming back from New York
where I was doing shows the last weekend
a couple weekends ago actually now so um
I'm very excited to talk about this
movie this was like a this movie is
always in my head as far as like the
mission impossible franchise even just
Tom Cruise movies yeah I'm not saying
it's the best it might even be the worst
Mission Impossible movie but the fact
that we're talking about Mission
Impossible 2 it's just near and dear to
my heart for reasons that I still can't
fully articulate maybe we can work it
out during the next hour I have a theory
about this because this movie was when I
really think of anything that mission
impossible was it embraced the style of
it because like John Wu may not be this
but he has the theatricality and Camp of
a drag queen and that is what it is
about this movie that is so so iconic
and it was like at the height of like
the MTV Movie Awards of it all it was
just such a different time like the
internet would not let this movie
survive today and I think that's why
it's such a great throwback but I'll go
ahead and ask our guests joining us
today to talk about the John Woo Tom
Cruise and I think by extension bill Ben
Stiller classic that is Mission
Impossible Too crit sir he's a writer
host and consultant welcome to Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong no thank you for
having me it's good to be here uh so
Thomas what is your what is your history
with mi2 like is this are you an Ethan
Hunt fan I've called him Ethan Hawke in
my head like eight times that's right
like what is your what is your sort of
relationship to this story uh you know
what I really like the Mission
Impossible movies I love Ethan Hunt as a
character and and as far as mi2 goes I
do not think it deserves I think along
the same lines as Mark like I don't
think it deserves the low rating it has
do I think it deserves the highest
rating absolutely freaking not but I
think you know for consistency sake I
think it's somewhere yeah it's it's not
worship yeah I mean it's the only rotten
movie out of the franchise and that
ain't gonna happen with dead reckoning I
don't think so I don't think so either
this is 56 on the Tomato Meter which is
like it's it's fresh adjacent but then
it's even lower with the audience 42
that's kind of where I think like I can
understand this movie being rotten with
critics the audiences I'm wondering what
left them cold I think people need to
appreciate how Mission Impossible came
out of the blue and ended up being a
good movie this was that sort of like
backlash to that because I remember when
the announced Mission Impossible
everyone's like what the cheesy show
from like the 60s where the like the
tape explodes like people were like what
like this is I remember this like Martin
Landau was at the premiere and people
were like oh you were in the original
like it was just like such a
disconnected
she's the research Department wait but
then didn't they they both like the
original cast they were like I hate this
film yeah it ended up being like a whole
the whole thing more more so than that
but yeah just like this idea that that
this movie ended up being so good as it
was it's almost like John Wick it was a
surprise and then imagine if the second
John Wick ended up being something that
was like a big disappointment I think
this got like a lot of backlash but
we'll talk about that either way we are
going to break down you know Mission
Impossible 2 because dead reckoning is
now out in theaters or it just came out
7 12. we're doing this the day after
um also go ahead and head on to
rottentomatoes.com and check out all the
Mission Impossible movies ranked by
Tomato Meter again the only rotten one
but there's these later entries are just
like kind of killing the game surpassing
anything else that we have I will say
this before we sort of get into it this
is courtesy of a fan shout out Alex
Heller who basically has decided that
this is the one we're going with today
so I I will say this I think we're gonna
have a lot to discuss I'm not in any way
sad about it but this is definitely a
movie where like all the parts were
supposed to work but didn't but Mark
before we get much further please tell
us what exactly is this synopsis of
Mission Impossible Too of Mission
Impossible too all right so Ethan Hunt
is a super agent he just wants to spend
some time on vacation but wouldn't you
know he gets called back into action
because there's this devastating virus
called Chimera and we gotta stop it the
scientists who are working on it some
nefarious things went down with them
there's a some sort of evil conglomerate
that's trying to get their hands on it
so they can have the virus and they care
because that's where the money is and so
we need Ethan Hunt to step in and stop
it before this thing kills possibly
everybody in the entire world he can't
do it alone it's up to Anthony Hopkins
who is his boss in this movie to tell
him hey you need to recruit whoever you
want but we gotta have Tandy Newton at
the time we gotta have her on board as
well she's a master thief and she has
connections to the person we're trying
to get at but maybe Tom Cruise has some
history with that same person too and so
it all ends up being a slam whiz-bang
action thriller and possibly the
greatest shampoo commercial I've ever
seen in my life the hair in this movie
is so
it makes me so insecure when I look at
my own locks in the mirror just gonna
say can't be drag queen he knows a good
wig like that was not even a wig that
was just like the natural hair that Tom
Cruise gave him but he knows the power
of hair any drag queen knows the power
of hair before we go any further he
looked at me when you sit there
but I was not gonna put the drag queen
on you I was just gonna put the idea of
like you understand what I mean
uh I I do want to ask real quick though
before we sort of like ask the
penultimate question is Rotten Tomatoes
right or wrong is which is your favorite
entry in this if you're such a big Ethan
Hunt fan like which is your favorite
listen I'm I'm a Fallout fan okay Angela
Bassett you got you I feel like the
action scenes of that like the the Henry
Cavill you know the the bathroom brawl
like nothing pumping the guns yeah
exactly you know why I got no guns to
pump but I I can't even physically do
that move yeah the Henry Cavill like
I've tried to do it and it just looks
like I like noodle I look like an
octopus like I can't do what Henry
Cavill does in that movie and Fallout is
the number one rated Mission Impossible
movie according to the Tomato Meter 97
certified fresh still a Ghost Protocol
guy Ghost Protocol yeah that's I was
just about is that Paula Patton yeah the
tallest building in the world sorry but
okay I'm gonna be so weird about this
call me a traditionalist I live for the
episodic feel of the first film yeah I
really do love the first one also it has
um Renee uh Jean Renee from um yeah from
uh professional uh and
what do you mean William H Bonnie Billy
the Kid himself
yes yes
he says yeah wow I can't believe I put
that on there I I did I did that ladies
and gentlemen I did that for you but
let's let's go ahead and get it down to
Brad's house Chris or I'm thinking I
know where you are on this but Rotten
Tomatoes wrong on this one I'm guessing
like or how far did you feel they are
wrong I feel like okay so I know you
said you love Mission the first mission
impossible I think that's better than
the first mission impossible the first
one you know it's iconic it's the
original you got the you know you got
the wire hang you got the uh you know
you have the introduction of these
characters but I feel like the acting
was so much better like the writing on
the first one's bad like and the first
one you know the the the IMF you know
director he's terrible you've watched it
he cannot act like it's it's just so
corny and I'm like okay I'm sorry but
I'm just like what is this honey like I
I couldn't I couldn't do him and I feel
like you know you got a much better
villain out of out of um Sean Ambrose I
feel like he's it and you got I don't
know they're just um
okay so it's giving Scandal a little bit
you know with with Olivia Pope running
between two white men you know like
that's what it's kind of giving with
Tandy with Naya but I think her
chemistry is great with Tom Cruise and I
feel like because you know I know that I
know the story is about
um about the virus and all that but
really it's about you know it's about
how Maverick I love exactly cruising
Tanny Newton fall overnight about
screwing once and now like they're just
even before they hook up just them
racing cars they're like you're the one
for you're the only one for me just
spinning around looking at each other
it's like I I I feel like 56 as much as
like I have strong like inclinations
towards this movie and like it I guess
it maybe it Contours like good memories
of of my past because I was like you
know I was 20 when this movie came out I
still feel like 56 is pretty much right
where this movie should be I love John
Wu and obviously I love the Mission
Impossible movies and Tom Cruise I could
I I could be happy with it getting into
fresh care territory but some part of me
much like the scar on Tom Cruise's face
at the end of this movie due to a knife
fight I like Mission Impossible 2 being
the scar on this franchise it helps it
stand out in a way so I'm kind of
perfectly fine with 56 the audience I
will take umbrage with 42 come on
audience get your act together that's
got to get higher wow okay so for the
style camp and just sheer awesomeness of
this movie I'd put it certified fresh
because this movie I I was literally
like watching like YouTube videos
getting ready for this because like I
don't need to watch this again and I
found myself like pulling up the movie
and I watched the whole thing actually
through because I've seen this movie a
couple times I don't think I need a
revamp on the on the plot or anything
and then I'm watching and I'm realizing
I don't even want to know this plot this
plot is ridiculous the virus the virus
like again it's just it feels I have
more thoughts on this but once we get
into it I have some I have some
reasoning behind why I I appreciate this
movie but basically what I was going to
say is the plot is a 46 the style is an
80. so like if you kind of average it
out that's kind of the where I feel on
this there's so many Bad plot moments in
this I cannot make this movie a fresh
movie but man it's pretty it's giving
drama pretty I love the drama anyway
let's have Tim remind us what critics
were saying about this film back at the
time
humans with Tim Brian De Palma's
eccentric take on the classic TV show
was certainly not bereft of great action
scenes Tom Cruise infiltrating that
computer room remains iconic but even if
it wasn't wholly successful Mission
Impossible 2 was where the series as we
know it begins less Intrigue and loads
more action to quote Roger Ebert the
first mission impossible had a plot that
no one understood Mission Impossible 2
has a plot you don't need to understand
by and large critics were impressed with
the cast but felt the incredible stunts
only did so much to distract from a
general lack of depth and character
development Mission Impossible 2 was
rotten at 56 on the Tomato Meter with
155 reviews and it has a 42 percent
audience score and just for comparison
the best reviewed installment of the
series Mission Impossible Fallout from
2018 is certified fresh at 97 percent
so what did the critics have to say in a
rotten review David Anson of Newsweek
called it a slick expensive bullet
ridden Thriller that is oddly dull the
last thing you'd expect however in a
fresh review Nicholas Sal of the San
Francisco Chronicle wrote it's fun it's
laughable it has moments of excitement
moments of sheer idiocy and moments of
sheer idiotic excitement
the Rotten Tomatoes critics consensus
reads your cranium May crave more
substance but your eyes will Feast on
the amazing action sequences so that's
Mission Impossible Too let's kick it
back to Jacqueline and Mark two people
who spend their weekends driving
motorcycles off cliffs
I wish that that's what I spent my week
watching movies which is why it
could call movie talk Brian Kelly good
[Music]
the person I know and you get on a plane
and like talk to people at bars Yeah
well yeah but I don't ride motorcycles I
don't do anything you'll never find me
on a motorcycle at least you're moving
you know I'm shaking I know it's just
kind of like yeah we're here I'm around
we're in a theater maybe at home we may
call each other to each other's houses
so guess what we can watch more movies
together
actually did watch on a plane yeah oh
you did I watched Mission Impossible 2
on a plane and I was so pissed because
one of the things that I loved about
this movie was the Metallica song I
disappear that they wrote for the movie
and it's the tag on the card they didn't
do it and because it's like it's a
planned movie and so they speed by it
and it's just the Mission Impossible
theme with the credits run up super high
and I'm like I was ready I was ready to
hear Lars and the boys and so no
Metallica but other than that it was it
was fun to re-watch and catch up on this
a franchise that I have gotten to know
since day one because I worked in a
movie theater wow it was the first
summer I worked at Carmike Cinemas in
Williamsburg Virginia was when Mission
Impossible had come out I think it was
either that April or May might have been
March but I so I could like on break
just pop in and like sneak in like watch
like 10-15 minutes of a movie yeah and
usually it was mission impossible I
think it was in May I tried to time it
with the Langley scene where he's
breaking it on the wire because that's
just so much fun and uh and then yeah
then this one coming out I was like oh
yes sign me up Cruz has longer hair he's
climbing rocks he's getting in knife
fights I'm in uh I don't know if I had
that with it um first I do have to go
ahead and say just overall with the
series this one is definitely one that
fans sort of like rail against it
doesn't sound like you rail against it
but what do you think is the part that
fans are the most like either happy or
upset about from this one like what is
the thing that they're either because
the hair happy I think we can all agree
but like I don't know what they were I
don't know what their biggest issue of
it was is even I was reading the reviews
there weren't these like as Tim was
saying they weren't like pitchforks for
it um yeah what's the gripe I don't know
going back to
the Shonda Rhimes effect before the
shoulder Rhymes affected happen I wonder
if that was a reason because you know we
didn't really have like Tom Cruise was
like the IT guy and I don't think he's
had any other black love interest in his
movie so I'm wondering you know could it
be one of those situations you know you
know you know the majority of the fans
of these toxic ass
back then like don't get me wrong like
there's definitely a thing but it wasn't
like a black love interest like that I
don't think was as revolutionary I don't
know I don't think so it didn't feel
like a jungle fever Revolution to me um
but but it's also because like this is
part of the mission I think we all like
kind of sign up for that where it's like
look if I'm working with somebody on a
mission because Anthony Hopkins told me
to and then I happened to end up having
feelings for them that's icing on the
cake yeah but like I still have to work
with you and the scene where she is
trying to break in and steal something
towards the beginning of the movie when
our our now star-crossed lovers meet
yeah I think that is such a sexy scene
yeah when they have to hide in the
bathtub and they're like on top of each
other it's like oh my you feel the
chemistry because it's not just Tom
Cruise's hair yeah it's also Danny
Newton's hair and John Wu knew he had
two devastatingly amazing locks of hair
great great lettuce on these two heads
this is what's so crazy asking John Wu
because like we do I think need to talk
about when we talk about why this movie
is rotten is talk about him because he
came he comes off a Face-Off which is
just so camp like everything that like
Nicholas Cage's character is doing on
both sides of that whether it's being
inside John Travolta or when he's with
me like both of them they're just like
chewing the scenery camp with all the
things how do you say let's go make that
dude make the freaking bureaucratic CIA
show like it seems like very strange
that he would even be the person to do
this don't you think I feel like the
tone was so different than what De Palma
did with the first one but it could I
mean I'm curious with you because John
Wu I kind of first got to know from Hard
Target the damn movie and like that
movie loves its slow motion shots face
off does too I feel like the slo-mo get
this movie would be 60 minutes if we
just ran it in normal time yeah but
there's so much slow motion does that
take because I feel like that's what
some critics were saying this movie's
dull because it does you're in a scene
and it so long because we're like
walking through quicksand molasses yeah
because we have to show these amazing
moves and all this stuff does the slow
motion get to you it doesn't get to me
like and I think there's so much action
in it for me to to balance that out like
that I didn't even that I didn't even
clock that as being something there
people would be upset by like and the
fact that Tom Cruise is out here doing
Capoeira he's given uh yeah he's doing a
lot like a lot of like I feel like as
far as fighting goes
he he was kind of at his most tactical
in this like he's doing acrobatics and
stuff I he's giving Liu Kang like he's
doing all these fancy kicks and stuff I
don't know I and then when he kicks the
gun up and everything like that like I
was just like come on now you're gonna
get mad at that action scenes for him
though or what are your favorite action
scenes for him and where he really sort
of like takes the action to the next
level in this one because I would say
that's the thing that everyone at least
loved about yeah well the motorbikes
yeah absolutely the motorbike uh you
know the the dueling I think that that
was uh yeah that was the jam and then
and then again the this the end fight
with Ambrose I I feel like he he was
killing it like I feel like that's
that's where you see him as at his most
physical in a fight across the series
yeah the fighting style he employs at
mi2 it's a young man's game yeah and
Ethan Hunt is older now he doesn't do
that I mean he's still jumping off Henry
Campbell in the last he was like he does
he actually does a lot in this last one
I mean not to like let too much away it
does but like the way he's contorting
his body in the fight scenes and in the
rock climbing scene in the opening he's
break dancing like but but to your point
just sort of like comparing and
contrasting like thinking about last
night I would say last night that let
there's some scene and I know which
scene you know what I'm thinking of
where it's like this and like that scene
I would say is the most physical he has
done in a long time in one of these
movies and that's like it's a scene with
him and palm yeah yeah I would say he's
done a lot more recent maybe that's the
throwback because I feel like the
further we get along now we start having
reverential moments two things and like
when you think about this one it's not
just that there's also like there's a
lightness to this one there's a comedy
to this one that I think they're also
like coming back to because this again
it's funny yeah and and you can look at
the plot of this movie and you can also
extrapolate it to where we actually
started the mission impossible as we
know now because what was patient zero
what was it the first mission Possible
movie or was it the rock climbing scene
yeah impossible too because that's where
it's like oh Tom Cruise is going to go
and do something crazy that no eight
actor should ever attempt in every one
of these movies and I still get nervous
for him when I'm watching the rock
climbing scene because it just looks
scary he's free solely he's doing this
stuff yeah so I was looking it up he
apparently did not have a safety net
there's nothing like on the ground to
catch him he had a harness and a thin
wire and he had two stunt guys and it's
so funny to watch the stock guys
interview because they have the same
exact haircut and they're like they're
ready to do it and Tom was pretty much
like guys I got this they're like uh
what and John Port John Woo is setting
the cameras up and he's like oh did Tom
is gonna do this and he's so nervous
yeah it's just so funny to watch like
how they were able to pull that off and
like I am not a Heights guy all right
I'm scared of snags and I'm scared of
heights I do not want to be high on like
up on stuff you know and like look over
so the fact that he's willing to commit
to this movie I think that's one of the
big selling points and it was in the
promotional stuff for Mission Impossible
too as well is like look at what this
guy's doing it's also one of those first
ones where like they're doing things for
the behind the scenes DVD like they want
to break down everything that they did
it's it's part of the selling this was
back when DVD sales were like huge and
so having those sort of special features
where they broke down exactly how Tom
the commentary and all of these stunts
is like worth it I think also at the
time with this y'all's first mission
impossible movie in a theater that you
saw no I mean I'm old so I I saw the
original you and I saw the original in
the theater yeah definitely not I
definitely saw both of these on HBO I
think Mission Impossible three uh was
which we should give flowers to as well
for sort of like like kind of
reinvigorating the franchise as well
after after this one after this one I
think this was back when they still
thought they were going to turn Ethan
Hunt into James Bond I think what you
really need to appreciate or what we can
appreciate now looking back on these
early injuries is like after Macquarie
comes on there uh Chris Macquarie comes
on there and sort of like changes this
style this lasts from whatever that is
Rogue or Ghost Protocol forward yeah
it's the style of the first one
modernized whereas in before they were
basically having everyone come in and do
their own sort of guitar riff this is
the John Woo guitar riff this is right
JJ Abrams guitar riff and I think they
still realize they're like as long as
we're still doing riffs this is never
going to be a consistent product and I
think like when you look at it now
that's why these later entries like look
at it I think you could look at Ghost
Protocol and dead reckoning and be like
I know exactly this they live in the
same world this movie lives on a
different planet yes and it's almost
like hey you can you can pick whoever
your team is and so we get Luther played
by Ving Ranch who we love in every
Mission Impossible movie and then we
also get the Australian helicopter pilot
who's a lot of fun in the movie as well
I disagree he gets on my nerves I didn't
like him no I mean I lived in the
streets for two years maybe it's
triggering but I he like they overdo it
they may make like every other word is
made
it was still good comic relief this is
the part of it that made me I don't know
it made you laugh maybe you didn't well
I mean I'm a big Ving Rings him but I I
feel like I don't know just the cast in
general they they would I feel like
they're trying to make it as
International as possible like you have
the South African guy as well it's not
even South African he's Australian and
he's putting on a South African accent
so they're trying to diversify it in
these in these interesting well maybe
not so interesting ways and and yeah
that we're really pushing their their
certain accent so see this is where I
will go back to like this is where I
know movie making at that time really
what it was at that time
of it it was the fact that John Wu was
this International director and they
knew people were going to be coming to
him looking for a certain type of movie
and I think they were worried about that
audience not feeling like this was a
John Wu movie because like I do think it
was like look they get to Palma on the
first one John Woo on the second they're
trying to find these iconic action sort
of directors and it's like I wonder if
it ends up being something that people
like later on is there anybody else
besides
Macquarie because he did uh the one that
you really like that you sort of look
back on the directors did you like the
JJ Abrams in iteration oh yeah is that
the favorite one
um wait which one did JJ Abrams
I still consider that I think
Christopher McCoy took the ball from JJ
pretty well and ran with it whereas the
first two movies like their own thing I
feel like you could trace the lineage of
what we get with dead reckoning yeah
back to mi3 it's a three yeah no I agree
with that three four and five I kind of
like almost into one for me and you know
three four five and six like yeah I mean
six definitely being on the Tilt but as
far as like rating like how i rate them
and they they all kind of as you said
have have the same sort of feeling or
you could yeah it's kind of funny like I
could put on a mission impossible one
two and I and I instantly know which
movie exactly yeah from three on them
like it those protocol helps because
he's got longer hair yeah he's got the
hair back you guys if by this point of
the show we realize I love these movies
because of Tom Cruise yeah this is
really I guess a guy grew up and my hair
is just it my hair is unapologetically
Curly and you're watching how this
straight hair is blowing in the wind and
I'm like it's never gonna look like that
on my head it's never gonna happen for
me go ahead no I was gonna say my only
group with four as they've been dreams
isn't in it like he's like just a you
know a little Cameo at the end he's just
barely yeah right and Paula I'm sorry
Paul you're beautiful but like it's like
it's giving great gowns beautiful gowns
like really yeah so do you think it
wouldn't be anything she never gives me
anything not to pit two black women
against each other but of the two do you
feel like and her chemistry with him was
more believable for it but here's the
thing though Paula Pan's character isn't
really a love interest for Tom Cruise
sure so yeah it's so it's not the same
thing as as true that's why you know
again going back to I just couldn't
understand why this film has the bad
rating it does I bet that's why I was
kind of you know alluding to that but um
I think Paula Patton's character is very
different as far as you know she's part
of The Ensemble he still got ilsa and
his wife kind of you know he's got that
uh Dynamic going on so she's India they
have a little patch a little kiss but
that's most
it's not really part of the romance of
it all I feel I feel like this movie
gets a bad rap and a lot of the critics
like what Tim was saying because the
it's kind of like a dull like like easy
story to tell and I'm like I kind of
needed that after the first one I still
have no idea what is actually happening
in the first mission I know there's a
knock list we don't want our agents to
get out in the open but there's so much
other crap going on between John Boyd
and Henry zerner who I think is great is
kittridge
I was just about to say I was like thank
you for bringing that back we need to
defend he maybe after little 1960s TV
show but that's sort of the fun that's
the whole point of it they're all doing
that and honestly that scene where he
was just like we've taught him how to do
it that is a great like just give me the
exposition of why we can't catch this
man that's how you build the legend that
is part of it that's how you make him
like a Jason Bourne fight it was an old
Exposition though that's what I think
like the writing was just like it was
too much and so then you get this movie
where it's simple it's like hey there's
a virus we got to stop it in time
there's a virus we got a crazy story to
tell yeah absolutely and an underrated
scene in this movie is because like like
the end scene is great with like the
knife fights and and the motorcycles
chasing each other and the beginning
obviously with the rock climbing I love
the scene where he's breaking into the
lab yeah that that kind of reminded me
of like the Wang Lee vibes from the
first one and then we get this really
cool shootout and this like oh well I
can't shoot her because she literally is
the only thing left for this like like
virus here so I thought that was like I
forgot about that and that is maybe what
I could use to push this movie into
fresh territory the music of this one is
also something that I think also kicked
into high gear because the very first
one did the mission impossible Like
Remix and was this the one went biscuit
baby yeah and so like just Brown out it
dates it but it also really I think adds
more to the movie and I think this one
actually had better music is there any
part of it that you like because there's
a lot of needle drops in this one
um no I like the music yeah I I feel
like you know Olympus is whatever but I
feel like it works for this film like
yeah I enjoyed it go ahead no going back
to the scene you're talking about that
going back to the drama of it all yo
when Tandy way
gives herself the shot like it's like
drama the whole way and then even when
she's like at the end where it's like is
she gonna is she gonna get the antidote
so she's like contemplating jumping off
the cliff like more drama like I feel
like that was like going back to you
know just nice not I like the way that
they filmed those I didn't realize how
much I cared about them as a couple
right until that point yeah that's the
whole story yeah like because you know
again if I'm on a mission you Jacqueline
Jacqueline knows this about me when I go
out to like a party or something I'm
Irish good buying every time I'll do a
lap I'll have a beer I'm there 15
minutes and I'm out I never say goodbye
I'm just out I put in some FaceTime I'm
out so I'm very non-committal yeah so
I'm always like coming at this from like
Ethan Honey's a secret agent he can't
have loyalty to anybody don't fall in
love don't make friends don't do any of
that crap you know just just live for
yourself in the mission but I see them
together I'm like God damn I really want
them to work
and they do I'm not getting the next one
until the beginning again this is where
he's like James Bond maybe this is me
differently but I just always think of
Ethan James Bond that's actually I got
mad when they started actually like
carrying over the women I just assume
that something happened between all of
the trauma that you're trying to
suppress from all of these missions that
made y'all break up in between between
movies like when they carried over his
wife I'm like no this is the episode is
over the girls disappear like the
girlfriend's on Seinfeld like they don't
come back I don't know have I been
drinking or is the end of Fallout where
like because he's always kind of keeping
tabs yeah and and the end of I think she
she met a dude right yeah right so she's
got a new dude and so now he's like okay
I gotta let this one go yeah right
because I was thinking like like as we
started the debt Reckoning I'm like wait
wait is is she still in the picture are
we still keeping an eye on her or what's
going on because I mean again by this
point we've done so many secret missions
um people know how to hurt you Ethan
yeah so you really can't have any
loyalties I want to know what happened
to Dandy Newton's character Also let's
be let's talk about the like I would say
infinite Riz of Ethan Hunt the fact that
he is just pulling in every one of these
movies sometimes he's got like three
girls where he's got like something
going on with romance sort of like this
one chemistry some pheromones Tandy the
top level Notch of all of the mission
impossible women
um because I think there may be a dark
horse that we we've met recently I'm
putting Tandy right there at the top
yeah so anyway as far as chemistry goes
I feel like she they have the best
chemistry but um but you know I feel
like his you know his soul mate or
whatever like that's his girl because I
think it's actually Rebecca Ferguson I
think she's now like top girl I I him
and Sandy do not chemistry man
lasted one movie it's like a great
season in sports like we didn't keep the
team back this isn't the run of the
Bulls in the 90s all right this is a
one-off but man it's like if the Detroit
Lions won a Super Bowl you know it's
like I don't know how it happened but
what a ride yeah I did want to talk too
about like just this movie was at the
time go live scientist I think they
actually have a shot this year
got that dude out of here and you're
gonna bring this up what is wrong with
you like I'm sorry you're gonna enrage
me just by saying I'm just saying I
don't Jordan love your chances oh my
Lord what team do you support the
Washington I mean come on glass house
man anyway sorry
now we'll bring you back from this
American football uh detour happens
every show
we really did hold it a bit but at this
time this movie was bigger than this
this is back when they were first doing
like the like um Ray-Ban like movie
tie-in like this like obviously I know
there's been sort of like product and
Industry placement but this was like the
height of it the summer movie box office
and again the thing that cannot be
missed is the Ben Stiller Mission
Impossible moment at the MTV Movie
Awards where he's like doing a stunt
double and he's doing the Tom Cruise
laugh and it was just like how did we
not know how unhinged all of this is
like just seeing that parody happen in
real time like it's I don't know it's so
nice yeah when Tom Cruise is climbing
the rock and he does that sort of like
Jesus move where he's gotta like you
know swing his other arm across and so I
was just like hanging and Ben Stiller
looks so much like Tom Cruise and he was
in really good shape then yeah like he
was a gym rat so you just put that wig
on him and it actually looks like Tom
Cruise it's such a great spoof and I
feel like Chris this is is the easiest
of the Mission Impossible movies to just
straight up Lampoon if you want to yeah
it puts itself out there it takes
chances with the way it was shot and I
think as a result it's very easy to
Lampoon yeah I agree and I think going
back to that period like MTV was I feel
like that's that was like the Pinnacle
of the MTV movie awards at least and and
I feel like it was it was the perfect
moment to capitalize off because they
land pruned so much oh excuse me they
they made fun of a lot of stuff during
that time yeah was that the last Great
era of MTV as far as like uh music and
then movies kind of like crossing over
like the the MTV Kanye took that moon
man from Taylor like that was the end of
it like that was the like line of
demarcation
seriously I can't wait for the 10 part
documentary where Jacqueline's a talking
head all over the history of MTV and
like that was the day the music died I
mean in my opinion I I honestly do I do
feel that also watching this over again
the one thing I will say when the doves
come up it's not cheesy to me it still
looks cool
when you see all these like or the like
smoke Mist like that he always manages
to make like every single great has like
Smoky stuff like all of that stuff I
would think would make me laugh now and
think of his parody still looks cool I'm
just like that yeah that's badass I
think kids nowadays would think that was
cheesy but I don't know would you think
gen Z would be down with John Wu I don't
know I don't know I don't know how you
can get mad at when he blows up that
door and it's like the frame of fire and
he like walks past like all Moody
looking and stuff it was giving the crew
I don't know I don't know if it smells
like the crew either but I listen I'll
tell you what Vibes that was that was
Michael Myers vibe that was I cannot get
rid of this guy
I will say one of the reasons why I
can't get this movie too high on the
Tomato Meter is I love a good Mission
Impossible movie and I love their mask
technology I give you one mask every
hour for every hour run time I'll give
you one mask this movie doesn't mask
like every 10 minutes no you're right
every 10 minutes flipping off mask is
and and it's just it's a little too much
masking for me interestingly enough I
think that's where this franchise goes
sort of like once you rely on something
now you got to break it
Mission Impossible movie but this one I
mean everybody putting them on throwing
them off because the first ones they
didn't have the voice remember that
because like in the very first movie and
like now they can like tape something on
your voice box to make you sound like
it's getting it's getting crazy that's
one of my favorite lines of Fallout 2 is
when Angela bass is like the the IMF is
Halloween it's a bunch of grown man
wearing my trick-or-treating I was like
yo she's so right and I feel like
they're relying on at least the same way
like the the wire drop in the first one
that they stop doing that at some point
right they stopped doing this I was like
hey you know what they're outgrowing
this thing so I don't know maybe maybe a
little less mask before we sort of talk
about dead reckoning which is coming I
did I do think we have to look at the
franchises and overview as far as the
stunts and we've already sort of talked
about the one with this one but like top
stunt overall like of everything that
they've done if you want to say it's the
most memorable the most crazy do you
want a minute yeah I need a minute I'm
ready to jump in this right now again
afraid of heights um I feel like the the
the free solo climb is it's just an
incredible thing to witness but when you
have the ability to say I climb the
tallest building in the world and the
way that that scene plays out in Ghost
Protocol where he's got like the sticky
things that he's climbing yeah yeah it's
just so cool because I feel like that
would be a really hard thing for me to
pull off I know it sounds scary anybody
can get strapped to the side of an
airplane and it maybe not it will but
anybody can do it and and you can
survive if you fly like at the right out
doing all that stuff you can strive
inside an airplane right now I'd have no
worries about it really yeah which is
weird because you're also like going
into Heights there but climbing Heights
is different than just like being on an
airplane I feel like I could nail the
airplane scene you're just hanging all
you're doing is hanging I can do that
wow what about you okay I had some time
to think about it and I think again
because I I get impressed by physicality
of things like there's the Fear Factor
but then there's also the physicality
and I think it's the I want to say it's
in Ghost Protocol well he's tied up and
also kind of comes in to save him but
when he's when he's got his hands tied
behind his back on their pole and he
literally like somebody's like he flips
himself upset upside down and like gets
off the pole that way like there to me I
mean I don't know yeah it's not as scary
as as or epic as the other ones but for
me I'm just like damn he did that
himself and he like he's just a physical
specimen to be you know just he really
is and I'll say you know present company
excluded when I say present company I'm
talking about dead reckoning I'm still
Reckoning with with watching the stunt
play on that movie because it is
spectacular yeah that again as I as I
will say this I'm not going to say what
happened because you know some of y'all
haven't seen it yet but in the middle of
the theater last night after in the
middle of one of the stuff
right next to her and he does something
and I'm just like he's gonna die and it
was like it was like it was purposeful
but it was also like involuntary like it
was like literally that's my this man is
gonna die he's gonna die doing this and
we should all be ashamed for making him
feel that he has to do this by giving
him billions of dollars at the box
office like at a certain point I think I
am valuing his life more than he is
valuing his life and I'm just like I
don't know if I can support this he's
gonna die well here's the interesting
thing about where Mission Impossible
could be going is because I like when I
heard the dead reckoning was going to be
like part one and part two I'm like oh
that they're gonna close the whole thing
up with that but then I heard like
Christopher McCoy talking about he has
ideas from Mission Impossible nine and
I'm like oh my God hold it hold on is it
still gonna be Tommy is it still gonna
the guy is literally Tom Brady just like
will not retire and he still ends up
being great I think every major news
organization should have a pre-written
Tom Cruise has killed himself on set
story written just for like
odds just good odds says that you'll use
it eventually I don't know when I don't
know where and I wish Tom Cruise no ill
will but sir you don't value your life I
just don't think I'm not saying it's not
brave what you did strap yourself to the
side of an airplane I could do it too
I'm I am not I'm still be on that point
neither of you should do it uh I will
just say for my favorite son is actually
proof of what I'm saying about him
killing himself the stunt where he was
it's not a crazy stunt but he jumps over
two buildings
the reason why I I look at that one is
because this man is the madman not only
does he want to jump on it but he's so
obsessed with the shot he doesn't show
that he got injured he like walks it off
yeah and like that's the shot they use
in real life in real life he broke and
shattered his foot he doesn't cry he
doesn't scream he like holds it in
cracked a bunch of ribs
just keeps going because the shot is
more important you do not value your
life sir you think the shot is more
important than just like doubling over
in pain I would double but I love that
shot in Fallout because like because
like at least people like in our space
knew like and it was pretty big news
yeah Tom Cruise was like seriously
injured doing a stunt so we know we're
bracing for that to happen yeah and then
we and then we're like at the scene he's
running on ribs like oh is this gonna be
him and then you feel it you feel the
the air come out of your own lungs when
you watch him slam into that yeah but I
think it's from the fact that he had
enough self-awareness to leave that shot
in there and not just make it this
glossy Ethan Hunt is perfect he never
gets injured like I love that he left it
in he's like hey I fail sometimes too
check this out it works for the movie
yeah again a testament also there is a
scene like that in The Lord of the Rings
where Aragon kicks a helmet where Viggo
Mortensen yeah but he screams he uses it
and makes it into anguish but he was the
we all want to be he was like
like I would not just hold that in that
was ridiculous not me man if I do a stun
that goes wrong yeah I'm yelling cut
we're not using that burn the film
immediately are you excited for dead
reckoning are you gonna get this opening
weekend because it's like it's weird I
feel like everyone has given up about
200 to the box office this summer
choices will have to be made listen I'm
I'm all in listen I I as I said the last
one was my favorite one out of older
than Fallout like I feel like you can
only go up especially with the success
of like top gun Maverick like it's like
come on what's next and I know he's
gonna deliver so I sound like a really
cute I sound like a Tom Cruise fan which
I'm not I just really like this French I
mean as long as he's making these movies
I will just I will let him make these
movies and I will watch them and that's
as much as I will say on the record it's
hard to not be that's all I will say
because the movies are so good like Top
Gun and top gun Maverick it's like would
I like those movies if another actor was
playing Maverick hell yeah it's Top Gun
it's Mission Impossible but he does lend
something special to it yeah and I think
part of that he is a great director and
I think part of it is just because he's
doing all this stuff yeah flying planes
he's actually climbing buildings and and
I think that does add to the experience
it adds to and he is a bona fide movie
star we're gonna get out of here but I
just want to add this last year he was
nominated for Top Gun he showed up at
the Oscar's lunch and this is a heavy
room this is famous people who don't
talk to famous people famous people you
know what I mean he was the most
everybody I mean everybody he is a
Bonafide movie star the fact that he
happens to be insane about jumping out
of planes is like the least interesting
thing about him but that wraps it up for
us here on movie talk
[Music]
I think that music is great for like Tom
Cruise attempting stunts too it's like
look at this guy he's obvious I'm doing
this crazy stuff I conquered the company
music I call it the Laughing music
because that's what it reminds me of it
suck it to me anyway why don't you sir
Mr kritzer sock us to your socials where
can folks find you and what are you
working on oh yeah um you can find me at
uh what would crit do Krit uh you know a
little shout out to Jesus uh and yeah
what am I working on right now what's
coming up um yo listen I'm exhausted I I
just came off aapi heritage month and
then pride month so I'm like I'm not
working on nothing if I can help it
um yeah exactly that's nap time so keep
an eye out uh I am working on a video
game but this this you know
still a couple years out of the making
so very cool yeah I'll keep you updated
and we can probably catch into theater
this weekend watching exactly yeah there
we go anything else you want to
recommend though that you're maybe
either watching or want other folks to
watch TV or movie
um I'm just gonna give a shout out to
all the Pacifica filmmakers out there
I'm a Pacific Islander and I'm always
going to give a shout out and give love
to um to the filmmakers out there so if
you want you can check out uh Vai on
Amazon uh Vai and uh and it really
showcases uh my people in a really
beautiful way nice very cool buy on
Amazon I will check that out all right
well that does it for us here on this
episode of Rotten Tomatoes is wrong if
you have a film that you feel just as
passionately about as Mission Impossible
2 please email us at Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong at rottentomatoes.com and wherever
you're listening to this make sure you
review rate and subscribe Mr Mark Ellis
what are we talking next week next week
is I think it's in two weeks and I just
don't know if I can wait this long to
talk about this absolute classic from
1990 that spoke to me as a child and is
an adult the live-action Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles yes the OG baby Shredder
Casey Jones Splinter this is Turtle
Power this is The Dark One
it does it gets dark this is the dark
one this is the one that had Parents up
in arms as they should be but still I
mean why we got secret of the use gotta
take care of Shredder somehow and I
won't hear it I won't hear slander
against secret of the use either are we
really gonna do this in a couple weeks
yes we are all right you guys can see us
here at Rotten Tomatoes is wrong again
for Brian's for Brian Perez Mark Ellis
and our guest today crit I'm Jacqueline
Coley we'll see y'all next week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]